big mike pineda in his career against
the national league in inner league they
will not play in the playoffs till
wednesday
akiyama
good way to start
continues to swing a hot bat
there goes akiyama not even a throw he
stole that one off of pineda his seventh
steal here in 2020. the reds have two on
and nobody out and joey votto's at the
plate the 2-0 pitch vato swings and hits
a bullet right between the second
baseman arayas and shortstop polanco
akiyama's around third to score winkers
into third votto into second it's an rbi
double for joey votto to put the reds on
top one to nothing
and he got the strikeout
three swings and misses on three sliders
wore away
in the air left field
rosario underneath of it tagging from
third is winker throw to the plate off
line two nothing reds
that's poke to right
kepler coming on making the catch in the
corner to end the inning
and luis castillo it's been a fine
september as you look at his numbers
overall
trying to toot himself up for the
playoffs but
it'll be sonny gray going tomorrow
they will not pitch trevor bauer here's
a ground ball galvez will feel it
and a blast to center field a base hit
and goodwin fields it in deep center
arise
digging for second and he's in with a
double what a great at bat
payoff
squibbler on the ground
so we'll advance the runner to third
two outs
right field down for a head and cruz
delivers the two out single and it's two
to one so far seven times in his career
i mean he did something better than
everyone else for an extended time
driven hard to right field kepler will
hope for a bounce he'll get the bounce
bottom digging for second here's
kepler's throw on target they got him a
perfect play in right field first
playing the carom and then the throw
points
position now they have a chance to tie
this game
that's to the left field corner and deep
going back as akiyama that ball hits the
base of the wall arise has another
double and the twins have tied the game
high fly right center field going back
is good one he's at the wall that ball
is off the wall it's another extra base
head another double and the twins have
taken the lead horizon from second base
got a good approach one through nine
to the backstop and gonzalez comes in
and he will score
and the twins get another run
on a wild pitch and it's four to two see
if verizon's able to put together
another quality at-bat
deep to left field nakayama going back
and that hits the base of the wall and
it's yet another double
all rise has three of them
and the team has seven back-to-back
singles for the reds first and second
and nobody out
breaking ball drops over for strike
three
the reds right-handed bats and that
would be nick castiano spanning for
shogo akiyama runners at first and
second base
and this is in the left center field gap
this will score one
as goodwin trots home it's a two run
game
what do you throw
right here you've got confidence in
breaking ball got him
and the pitch a ground ball to shore
polanco to his left he feels he sits he
throws in time out number three now the
reds load the bases they do score one
but leave three luisa returning
to the lineup after a stint on the
injured list with three doubles
[Applause]
into the right field corner
and arise will just get a single but
he's got a four hit night and the twins
answer with at least one in their half
of the seventh inning
rosario into center field
see senzel's arm runner tags at third
here comes the throw to the plate now
the runner going to second base throw
down and they got it i think this has
probably been the most complete game
offensively we've seen from the twins
in a while
and a strikeout duffy gets the first out
very quickly
and duffy picks up another strikeout two
down
[Applause]
and the magic number for the minnesota
twins is one